you know a series pay attention we
explore ways to sharpen our focus and
recapture our attention from distracting
technology this morning we follow our
mother's advice who said why don't you
go play outside Americans spend an
average of 93 percent of their time
indoors or inside a car that means just
12 hours a week is spent outside there's
mounting scientific evidence that
spending time in nature is good for your
body and your brain that led us to
explore a popular activity prescribed by
Japanese physicians for years it's a
practice known as forest bathing notice
what sounds are around us
notice the sense that are in the air
notice the air as it moves around your
body over the river what colors do you
see and through the woods
what textures nestled in the vibrant
forests of New York's Harriman State
Park I'm gonna just invite you to wander
we join a small group of first-time
forest bathers I heard so clearly forest
paving is the practice of immersing
yourself in nature by engaging the five
senses I really like the opportunity to
just be alone I like that it was
completely silent this is not a hike
there is no destination or goals this is
about discovery and awareness I would
ask that you hold the intention that
whatever you see in front of you you're
seeing that for the very first time
Annabelle O'Neal is like any other 20
year old we must slow down use our
childlike curiosity to explore active
online and posting to social media but
she also carves out time to break free
from those digital distractions
it's why she trained to become a
certified forest therapy guide
technology is kind of taken over and
we're so disconnected with it and I
think forest therapy brings people here
that brings people together it brings
people to the present moment I try to be
out walking every day dr. Eva cell hub
who wrote a book about nature's effect
on the brain says we are wired to seek
out information which can feed an
addictive cycle with technology how do
we use nature to stop this cycle of
stress and shredding that everybody
falls part of the issue with nature is
that the lack of nature is causing part
of that shredding when we are exposed to
nature there's this aw effect that
happens literally going from feeling
closed to feeling open and connected to
feeling like we belong dopamine gets
released our immune system is improved
and the stress response is decreased so
all of the wiring that has been where
against you when you feel stressed can
work for you if you find yourself in
nature that's right in fact nearly 15
years and millions of dollars of
research much of it in Japan reveal
spending time in nature can reduce
inflammation depression and anger while
improving cardiovascular health
cognitive function creativity and
concentration being out nature gives us
that second just you know take a breath
and the minute you do that you open up
the brain centers to be able to
concentrate more on what you do need to
do there seems to be some resetting of
our attention span in natural spaces
paediatrician nousheen razani says
children especially need access to
nature to develop properly sometimes I
get concerned that the more that
interaction is with a screen and less
with actual people and places the less
opportunity kids had to develop the
emotional and social skills that it
takes to get through life
it's why she actually prescribes nature
to help parents who can't seem to pry
their children or themselves away from
their cell phones
there are studies showing that there are
specific health benefits to a forest but
if it can't happen in the forest and it
happens on the corner of your street
that's still important because whether
you are a digital native kid on a nature
walk holding a bug for the very first
time or a grown man playing king of the
mountain your body and brain will soak
up the benefit what do you want people
to get out of forest baby I guess I just
want people to get more grounded and
remember what it was like to be 7 again
doing something just because it's
calling you or you feel like doing it
like stretching out at a full reach in
hopes of discovering crawfish under a
rock studies show natural chemicals
released by plants have a positive
effect on our stress level and immune
response and it's cumulative so the
benefits from a weekend in the woods
will last at least a week there is also
evidence that pictures of nature have a
similar effect so
yawn I've known you for a long time
we've been on the campaign trail many
moons ago I've never seen you leaning
over a rock that shot at the end there
were crawfish underneath really they're
very good for your mental health as well
across bishops so Judah profesh man
happier if you're peckish good for you
as well Double Trouble go